this is Sal here and I'm with Kim Cutts
who's Khan Academy's American history
content fellow and but what I'm curious
about is you know in school you learn
about the Civil War you learn about
slavery that slavery was a cause of the
Civil War but at least for myself I
never got a full context of you know
what were all the dynamics that led to
the civil wars it's just something that
happened overnight oh definitely not you
know I think the seeds of the Civil War
were really with the United States at
its creation you know I think there's a
sort of an essential contradiction in
the United States as it's born you know
where this country where all men are
created equal except that most of the
states in the south have slavery where
people are clearly not created equal so
you know they couldn't win the
Revolutionary War without including
those states and kind of giving them
what they wanted in retaining slavery
but it means that you know the u.s. is
born with both free states and slave
states and they're going to continue to
try to figure out how to balance those
for the rest of the 1800s and we have
this map here this map is a later period
but it shows the this is actually closer
to the Civil War but if we leaving to
look at the original 13 colonies you can
see which ones were free states and
which ones were which ones were slave
states and then you obviously have these
other states that come in later which
will which we'll talk about but this
what you're saying is the founding of
the country this was already an issue
people are you know there were people in
the North who weren't fans of slavery
and people knew that somebody's being
irreconcilable or maybe they hoped it
would be reconcilable a difference
listen we got to unify against Great
Britain I guess let's just become a
country and do it you know even Thomas
Jefferson the author of the Declaration
of Independence he knew that slavery was
a contradiction he called the issue of
having slavery like holding a wolf by
the ears right you can't hold on to it
but you can't let it go because so many
of the wealthy elites who are going to
end up in Congress in the south our
slave owners so they want including
himself exactly so they want to protect
their interests so we have that that
it's you know that the issue is there
from from the
the moment that the country is founded
and then we get into the 1800s which is
really the run-up year the Civil War
doesn't start until you know we get into
1860 or shortly thereafter what or
actually 1860 what what is you know what
are what are the what's the big picture
that really leads up to it well I think
what we're looking at when we get into
the issues that lead to the civil war is
really about how the u.s. handles
getting new territory right the u.s. was
getting a lot of you territory we have a
map here it's the first really big chunk
is you have the Louisiana Purchase in
1803 and so you get all of see let me
shade it in you get you know roughly all
of this stuff right over here so that's
new areas that it settlers can go and
write and and it comes officially part
of the US and what else happens so you
know as we get these new territories out
of them you're going to get new states
and when new states come into the Union
they're going to come in as either free
states or slave states so you know we've
balanced the interests of the north and
south up until this point right from the
Revolutionary War so that there's equal
representation in Congress between free
states and slave states well why does
why does someone care if I'm you know if
I'm someone in Massachusetts why do I
care whether the new state of Missouri
is going to be a free state or a slave
state well I think there there are two
reasons why you might care first you
know if you're an abolitionist and these
are the people who we know very well
like Frederick Douglas or William Lloyd
Garrison who was the editor of the
newspaper The Liberator these are the
people who feel that correctly slavery
is morally wrong you know slavery is a
corruption of the essential principles
on which the country was founded um it's
something that you know destroys lives
destroys families but another reason if
you're say in Massachusetts or
Pennsylvania why you might care whether
a new Slits
state is a slave state is you're worried
about opportunities for yourself out
West you know we know that horace
greeley this famous newspaper editor he
says what do you do if you're a young
man
and new york and young white man who
doesn't know how to get ahead he says go
west young man you know you can go out
there you can get some land you can
start a farm but if you go out there and
you find that all of the land has been
bought up by rich slaveholders from the
south you might not be able to get any
land and you certainly might not be able
to for example sell your corn at a rate
low enough that you could beat somebody
who has free labor so there was a lot of
times there's a lot of focus on the
moral argument which is a very strong
argument but there's also this this
interesting economic argument which you
just talked about which is it's hard to
compete with slavery I mean you're
literally talking about labor that does
not need traditional wages right that is
literally slave labor and so if you are
having your own farm and you aren't you
don't own slaves how are you going to
compete with that and so those are some
folks in the north on economic argument
now with these people be considered
abolitionists know the way that we think
about those we call them anti-slavery so
anti-slavery advocates they they don't
think that they can get rid of slavery
in the South even if they don't like
slavery in the South they don't even see
how it'd be possible to get rid of it
but they do think that as these new
states are coming into the Union they
could prevent them from becoming slave
states so that it's possible for the
western lands to remain free you know
Abraham Lincoln I think is a really good
poster child for this well I think we'll
talk about him a little bit more later
but Lincoln is born in Kentucky one of
these new western states his father is a
small white farmer and slave owners move
into Kentucky later it becomes a slave a
slave state and his father can't find
work his father can't find land so he
ends up first having to move to Indiana
then moving to Illinois so this is
literally a case of one of these poor
white farmers who just can't compete
with slavery which is one reason why
Lincoln himself is later going to come
out so strongly in favor of making sure
there's no slavery in the web
so abolitionists want slavery is is is
amoral it needs to be removed from
definitely the United States possibly
the world anti slavery they also think
slavery is bad they don't like it right
up they think it's a well but I'm not
going to fight that fight to remove it
but maybe that's hard to do or
impossible but it shouldn't spread it's
not fair it's the reason my dad wasn't
able to be able to run his farm
absolutely and so when we get it so
that's you know you have the Louisiana
Purchase anyway in other videos we talk
it's famously Napoleon sold it for quite
cheap because that he couldn't defend it
because he was not even tours and he's
fighting these wars in Europe that's the
big that's the first chunk of land so
you have all of these states and they
need to figure out whether their slave
slave states are free states but why
would I mean I talked about why would a
northerner care whether a slave or free
trade why would a southerner care why
would I may if I'm a slave owner I owned
a plantation in South Carolina or
Georgia why do I care if Missouri is a
slave state or a free State well I think
you know just as their political
interests are tied up in slavery all of
their money is tied up in slavery you
know in 1860 the most valuable thing
that anyone owns in the United States is
slaves right you can't you can't compete
with that kind of money so they want to
make sure that if a new state comes into
the Union that state isn't a free state
because then the free states might have
more representation in Congress and then
they can vote to outlaw slavery so if
your whole fortune is built on slavery
if you're a white slave owner they
outlaw that then you're left with
nothing I see so in the north there's a
moral argument there's the economic
argument slavery slavery is hard to
compete with and the South hey if we
have too many of these free states at
some point they're going to have a
majority you know enough of a voting
power in the government to to to maybe
abolish slavery one day which would
completely undermine if I'm a slave
owner my you know my
my economics of my reality right I mean
and they are sort of essentially amoral
even you know someone like Jefferson who
knows that slavery is wrong his whole
wealth his whole fortune his whole
political dynasty is built on the
fortune of owning slaves and and you
know one of the the first points where
this you know this really gets balanced
this issue is we have Louisiana Purchase
in 1803 then starting to carve out the
Louisiana Purchase you have states like
Missouri they get to their critical mass
of people of populations so that they
can become a state and so what was the
Missouri Compromise all about in 1820
so the Missouri Compromise is when we
have enough people living in Missouri
you know these are white people
generally coming who have come from the
eastern states and they apply for
statehood you've got an equal number of
slave states and free states already in
Congress so if Missouri comes in they
want to be a slave state they're going
to upset the applecart they're going to
upset the balance so there will be more
representatives for the south than there
will be for north and everything they've
done so far has been predicated on this
sort of tenuous balance between free
states and slave states so you know they
debate this in Congress just four months
and eventually what they do is say all
right well we can't decide so we're
going to do is admit the state of Maine
at the same time and administer the
territory of Maine was already part of
the United States what I mean how is it
not already a state it was part of
Massachusetts but as you can see you
know it's really only tenuously
connected to Massachusetts so they
divide this territory up so that it can
have its own representation in Congress
so they say all right we can't solve
this problem of the balance of power
between free states and slave states
right now so what we're going to do is
just kind of extend our balance we're
going to keep this compromise going to
make sure that they're the same number
of free and slave states so we'll let
Missouri in
as a slave state at the same time we let
Maine in as a free state fascinating so
I think and I mean I see where this is
going that you have these very tenuous
compromise while more and more
territories being added it's exciting to
see where all of this goes